Speaker 1: Remember that the David Pakman
show is made possible by our viewers and listeners
wherein we have the membership program and
here as it is, the way that we fund the show,
I invite you to sign up at join Packman dot
com.
We do have the coupon code 24 starts now which
you can use.
And I'll just mention this.
It's how to know I shouldn't really be mentioning
it but we had a tick tock live stream on February
28th, the last day of the month and we had
like a one day only coupon code tick tock
fab and it is a pretty aggressive coupon code.
We didn't really turn the code off at the
end of February, so you can still use it and
it's like an even bigger discount.
Tick tock fab.
Let's get to hearing from some people in the
audience.
I can't think of anybody more important than
the folks who make this show possible through
their viewership and listenership.
We take calls on Fridays at join pack at David
Pakman dot com slash discord, rather, and
you can join the discord that way.
Let's start today with oh, I don't know.
It's so hard to say.
How about Joe from Massachusetts?
Joe from Massachusetts, Welcome.
Let's all hope for no technical trouble and
that we have an auspicious start today.
Okay.
Speaker 2: How do I sound, David?
Speaker 1: You sound good.
What do you have, like, a creaky door there?
Speaker 2: Oh, that's my chair leaning back
on my beard.
Speaker 1: Oh, no prob.
Maybe some dry lube would deal with that noise.
Speaker 2: Maybe it would stick it up and.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy, now you're starting to
cut in and out, Joe.
Let's hope we can get a question here and.
Speaker 2: I'm still bad.
Speaker 1: Okay.
I heard that.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Like the boat.
George Anthony.
The Voltaire.
Santos?
Yes.
The third Nobel Peace Prize winner for his
contributions to nuclear fission.
So my quick disclaimer right before I get
to the question is that he should resign because
his voters voted for somebody else, basically.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
Speaker 2: But my question is, I want your
take.
What did actually be beneficial to the left
if you stayed on?
Like each week, a new woman, a new line, new
scandal and more infighting on the right.
Would it actually benefit the left if you
actually just stayed?
Speaker 1: I think that the way in which so
here's the thing if George Anthony David there
Santos the third junior senior stays.
I think the way that it's useful to the left
is that they can continue to make it a story
that this guy has been allowed to stay by
the Republican Party and show how low their
standards are and all these different things.
The trick to it is they have to keep it in
the news and they have to constantly find
new lies and things to talk about because
otherwise it'll just sort of fade away.
You're not going to get two years out of this
unless you can keep finding new lies.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
I'm scared to see where it all leads up to.
That's all we can do.
Yeah, it happens.
Speaker 1: But honestly, it would be correct
for him to be forced to resign.
That would be the right thing.
Speaker 2: Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yeah, I just wanted to make that disclaimer.
So, 100%.
Thanks for taking my call.
It was my first time using a discord call.
I'm glad it didn't go too bad.
Speaker 1: No, you did relatively well after
we sorted out that.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you, Joe, from Massachusetts.
Great to have you on.
Speaker 2: All right.
Take care.
Speaker 1: All right.
There goes Joe.
Very, very powerful declarations made there.
Let's go next to gets from Alberta is that
Alberta?
Canada gets.
Speaker 3: Yes, that is.
Speaker 1: Well, welcome.
Speaker 3: Oh, and he's got of the show.
I'm just curious, you've ever seen the documentary
The Territory on Disney Plus?
Speaker 1: No, I have not.
What is it?
Speaker 3: Oh, it's just an environmental
that's for the indigenous peoples.
I'm a little nervous.
You're doing good people in the Amazon and
they're fighting the expansion of this timber,
basically.
Industrial colonization.
Interesting tastic watched if you haven't
seen it.
The only ask that I have of your show is that
be kind of cool if you had some Indigenous
speakers talking on indigenous issues.
Speaker 1: Indigenous to where.
Speaker 3: If it's a North American issue,
then grabbing someone from the local nation
that could talk about that.
I know there are totems right now are always
in a state of perpetual battle with the oil
companies and the RCMP, and they have activists.
They have land defenders that would, you know,
love to talk and spread the message and raise
awareness.
Speaker 1: I think that's a very interesting
idea.
We will look into it immediately.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's I love the show.
I just the awesome Seymour Brown and black
people specifically people from those nations
and that's the only Oscar I have.
I think you're amazing.
Your debate I don't think was a debacle.
It was really weird watching some guy play
40 chess with himself.
Speaker 1: You mean.
You mean the Patrick.
But David won.
Are you talking about PBT?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 3: It was.
It was interesting to watch somebody beat
themselves in 4D Chess and you're just sitting
back and watching like, what are you talking
about?
Speaker 1: There were so many dimensions that
they were playing against themselves, essentially.
Speaker 3: That was great.
So that's all I got to say, just to be nice
to see more Indigenous folks.
If you need a hook up, I can send some like
our representatives if you want contact information
too.
Speaker 1: All right.
Gets from Alberta.
I appreciate the suggestion.
Thank you.
John.
All right.
There he goes.
It's great
to have him on.